the opponent is you and the opponent but
you know in real life you still like
sometimes chest is life that's that's
what you don't understand but the chess
game is the is the only thing that
matters so but you have some friends
don't you hun yes but they're but I I
take pleasure in their pain what like
when I see many many people here when I
see them lose I I but this is this is
not like a controversial thing everyone
takes pleasure in their enemies losing
this is not like people just lie and say
oh you know well I'm so respectful oh
love oh we're just everyone such no no
no you and like I'm sure this entire
playing hole when I lose they take
Serious pleasure in that okay I'm I'm
just telling you I'm just telling you
but but you know we all uh we all what
about friendships H like there's no
friendships on the chess board uh there
on the chess board but what about
outside of the CH chess is life life is
chess like
the the game chess continues on and off
the board okay it is a continuous and
Perpetual game of chess until death